Vsauce. Michael here with a new
episode of "Up All Knight."
Vsauce.
Michael here today with a new episode
of "Up All Knight," a show where I cover cool, geeky
trick things.
For instance, we all know Yahoo.com,
but do you know what happens when you click
on the dot in the exclamation point
after "Yahoo!" ?
"YAHOOOOO!"
Next, let's talk video.
VLC is a free media player that
lets you do some cool
things.
Open up VLC, go to Preferences,
Video, select all, click on Video,
Output modules and choose color ASCII art
video output.
Now, my episode of Bill Nye is made out of
text.
I can also make my wallpaper my desktop wallpaper
animated and move.
Go to preferences, video,
all, and under an output module you'll find
"Use as desktop background." Ta-da!
Now I can work right on top of Bill.
For my final trick,
let's download some YouTube videos.
Just copy your YouTube URL
and open it as "network."
Then go to window, media information,
and boom!
That is its secret location.
Depending on your browser it will either
take you to a full-screen version that
you could download
or immediately start downloading the
video at full quality.
Google can be a lot like old-school
Napster. Use code number one in this video's
description to search for downloadable
audio files. Just put the keyword you
want between the double quotes
and sweet, look what I found.
Not big enough?
Well, try to add "admir7656's" recommendation of
epic Google. It just keeps growing and
growing and growing
until you search.
You can also try Weenie Google.
It shrinks and shrinks so fast.
Mac users,
did you know that the application icon
for Text Edit has a message
on it that you can read if you zoom in
enough? And Windows users,
paste code number two in the notepad,
save it as a ".bat" file,
open it and play tic-tac-toe.
If you have not yet seen
every episode of "Up All Knight,"
make today the day you do it.
You can click any of these to watch previous
episodes,to learn stuff like how to
reveal passwords
and a couple, well, way more than a couple, pranks.
Subscribe to Vsauce for more and get
excited for Saturday,
when we're gonna have brand new Leanback...s. and as always
And as always,
thanks for watching.